America we hope you are ready for a
brand new Kamala the Veep is ready to
move past numerous setbacks a massive
staff Exodus and cringe World these
speeches like this
I think of this moment as a moment that
is about great momentum you need to get
to go I need to be able to get where you
need to go to do the work and get home
when we talk about the children of the
community
they are a children of the community the
significance of the passage of time so
when you think about it there is great
significance to the passage of time
you're going to literally see the
craters on the moon with your own eyes
with your own eyes I'm telling you a new
report from Politico
claims the vice president is in a better
place after the midterm results and
ready to hit the road to show off the
new and improved version of herself one
former Harris age saying quote now that
it looks like Biden's running she's
really being treated like what I would
call a normal vice president there's
just less attention which I think
actually frees her up to focus on
excelling and not have to worry about
the Relentless scrutiny
and one white house Ally claims Kamala
is just misunderstood quote one of the
challenges that this administration had
is I don't think that the White House
writ large fully understood what it
meant to have a historic first vice
president you have to put her out more
you have to put her out front more on
some things because it looks different
and it is different right
Kamala is already making progress by
literally standing up to Biden
okay
[Applause]
all right so
um I'll I'll ask you this Greg that
they're saying that less attention on
her now freeze Kamala up to excelling
okay why is there less attention on her
now because Joe's running explain that
to me I I just think it's a marvelous
coincidence as the media and Democrats
are gently trying to pry the car keys
away from Old Joe they're now talking
about what a great improved driver
accommela is so maybe this is just a
slight push push back into the spotlight
but she says she's in a better place a
better place than where because I don't
know where she is like I don't know
she's like you know Amelia Earhart has a
bigger footprint than her I mean they I
mean they've shrunk her so you can't
talk about her anymore I'm running out
of things to say she's one step above
you know the ladies that open the
briefcases on dealer No Deal
you know but it's not her fault this is
where I defend her uh because she is a
great American she is not her fault in
this hiring phase it wasn't like they
were looking for confidence or stressing
capabilities to that person's point
whoever said that it was all about the
historic first and the historic first
now is an obsession every time the Dems
are in power because they use it as a
cudgel against Republicans like if you
want to vote for a republican then
clearly you don't want to be part of
this historic first you must be a racist
you must be you know a bigot of some
kind but then you look at all of the I
think I did this before it feels like
I've said this before but that doesn't
stop me the list of historical firsts
are also historical failures Sam brotman
Rachel Levine Kamala kjp Lori Lightfoot
Pete bootage even Joe Biden's a
historical first and a failure he has
the first president with no brain
connectivity so I think it's effective
the historical first is effective in
getting the person in but lousy at
getting the right person in does that
help I hope so no but thank you thank
you no thank you no thank you no thank
you all right
um let me ask you Harold because you're
very reasonable good to be back
as resonance today
you're a reasonable man she says that
the pressure is not on her anymore
because she doesn't have to put in that
boat when the Senate's tied what else is
she doing
well look
this is this is politics I think she she
has shown two things once she's shown
she can be successful in electoral
politics she was elected to be district
attorney elected to be attorney general
elected to the Senate she needed to run
a particularly great campaign for
president but ran well enough to be put
on the ticket
but I take him at their word she needs a
reset the president in the country could
use her being a more reliable and
effective partner for the president I've
urged on this show many many times if
she tackled border security in a way
that we've laid out elements here on
this on this show you all have laid out
elements on your shows uh it would go a
long way towards helping not only
President Biden but the country second
she has more experience than anybody in
this Administration to deal with crime
she was a D.A and she was an AG of the
biggest and most populous state in the
country can you imagine if she went
around the country collecting best
practices ideas things that are working
police officers interacting with
communities police officers being funded
DA's that are actually why isn't she so
these this would be my advice to her to
her judge and she has you know whether
President Biden runs again in two years
I believe he will this is not any kind
of trying to be coy or acute with words
or if he decides to run and he's
reelected or he's not re-elected she'd
run in four more years this is the time
to build that body of work and if I were
them I'd stop talking and I'd start
doing
you're a woman how do you feel about her
Dana
um I've I've
I don't know necessarily think of her as
just a woman I think of her as a
disappointment in terms of a vice
president and also she there was
something about that historical first
that gave us a little bit of okay this
is this is gonna be the first one and
then she basically whiffs on every
policy that she's been given including
the most important one which was the
border and she didn't do anything with
it so I think that is not good for her
or well not good for the country mostly
but she is having a great couple of
weeks
who's had a worst week Pete butterjudge
last week he was on the hook for all the
failures that are happening in
Transportation around the country and
she sat back and watched that now Biden
is on the hook for all of these
documents and watch very carefully to
see how she ever responds to that if
they let her do an interview does she
throw him a Lifeline or a brick and
we'll see how that goes they had 35
different staff changes for her to get
to this point yeah my slight
exaggeration but not much however many
people left her campaign and then on the
record said why they left her campaign
the people who left the White House
Staff office and were on the record
saying why they left because it was
chaotic she wasn't a leader she wouldn't
listen to them maybe now all of a sudden
she has a great staff and that's
wonderful but I have to wonder how is it
that the media that the editors keep
getting talked into writing this story
this is not the first time we've done
this story she's always just on the cusp
of showing us how really great she is
well I'll sit here and wait to see that
and being in the Biden Administration if
you're the principal it means never
having to be responsible it's always the
staff failed you or somebody else's
fault nobody ever takes personal
responsibility for anything so I'll just
believe it when I see it um she was a
terrible boss that's what those what her
staffers said so let's see if she can be
a better vice president now with new
staff you know Jesse the one thing that
she was uh charged with was being the
borders are and I find fascinating that
I've never seen a report on the border
as to the root causes but I think it was
yesterday that New York city mayor Adams
said it's his credit I'm saying credit
to Mayor Adams he said we need a
national borders are and I thought to
myself her own party doesn't know what
her job is yeah that's embarrassing and
if I was by and I'd be mad because the
week the important special counsel to
investigate you the next week your VP
comes out with a piece that says you
know what things are going great for the
vice president permission to make an
analogy yes this would be like Greg
Gutfeld nearly drowning
and the next week
Jesse Waters communication shop
placed a piece in Politico that said
prime time is walking on water
it would be in poor taste
and I read this whole piece it's
your typical girl power psychobabble how
is Kamala feeling the first line of it
is New Year New You I'm in a better
place I don't like all the attention I'm
getting and now she feels free to be
normal Dick Cheney was shot in the face
did anyone write a thousand words about
how dick was feeling wait he must have
shot somebody he shot somebody in the
face whatever someone shot someone in
the face
shooter okay how about this
president
anybody write a thousand words about how
Mike was feeling yes
but Politico surely didn't
my point is your permission is denied on
this message
permission was granted okay she said
about Gerald Ford she feels he fell on
his face coming out of the plane
listen she feels a sense of comfort she
feels a sense of flexibility I don't
even know what that means do you know
what it means to be freed up freed up
from what right they had a piece a
paragraph that said after returning from
holiday break Kamala Harris sat her
staff down and went around the table and
Kamala asked everybody what their word
of the year was and her word of the year
was momentum imagine Bush vice president
in the 80s for Ronald Reagan sitting his
staff down
excuse me what is your word of the year
they were fighting communism they didn't
have time for staff meetings about what
they were of the year come on and now
she's saying on the same day she's
saying she doesn't care about politics
she's not running
she's giggling at mayor Pete for
botching the airplanes being being
grounded exactly so she's just a dunce
and I you know I feel bad for Joe Biden
okay are you done I do okay coming out I
have another analogy no denied I wanna
Brian kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now